and planet poppup like that painted pop
pop or my property property
Denver's at [ __ ] it's me when I'm
[ __ ] a mini aleni
get your life together touch me bro I'm
not touching
you bring 1 min to a damn breath
festival brother who this chronic times
huh cronut dimes Gabi sure what are you
keeping up permits at the house yeah
spread them out you do seem like the
kind of guy who would open up a can of
mints at home and leave most women at
home dude that seemed like a total
youtube comment somebody were right
Brendan seems like the kind of guy that
would open up with the commenced and
leave most of what was the best youtube
comment that I ever heard the funniest
when I it's a little racist but it's so
funny
they said Chappelle looks like Wesley
Snipes in blackface I've never been on
YouTube though my Instagram comments and
you bring it up one day he isn't here I
know we've never talked about it sorry
Chappelle the one day he isn't here
that's when you bring it up doing what a
snake the mouth the Malibu night
stockers not here dog Malibu rum get the
day off
oh he's definitely every time I see
Chapelle I think of the solar eclipse
oh my damn is it March 22nd gotta start
off with the fact that obviously Brendan
looks just like his cartoon dude do you
think I dress like this Doug I'd ever go
the yummy little thing on that cartoon
they got you looking all cute you know
damn well you want a cute kid
you tell you to make it a little more
realistic are you wearing why are you
wearing that headband again dude dude
this is an activity ban there's a male
activity band it's a male activity band
yeah dude you look like you're in the
worst 80s band
rock band of all time yeah ACJC
[Laughter]
do you look at a [ __ ] hit man in a
sperm bank do you listen you look like
you have lap dances at a spelling bee
[Laughter]
using a sentence with the origin of the
word origin the word we said F a couple
times though no we did it we didn't know
profanity
apparently YouTube really shows for kids
I guess yeah well apparently we do hit
actually hundreds of video to the people
sitting or watching with their children
really alarming do it really uh yeah
mention you or two teachers the poor
kids [ __ ] kids would be let how about
everyone's like damn Chappell got a lot
black we got mark here today man you
want to introduce some new you want to
introduce everybody to our new culture
corner yeah well we got as you the the
usual suspect cat over here hey cat hey
hey hey and then we brought in put up
the Irish flag got mark Hayes in the
house the pride of where you from mark
car Cork Ireland and what is it exactly
what are they known for its northern
island right now it's out them yeah
fifty percent this who wants to be a
millionaire percent and you got it wrong
no good dude shoot yeah we're all for
cheese some good cheese yeah some good
whiskey oh yeah how are the ladies in
Cork
[Music]
grass is always greener on the other
side of my man ya know I'm like
love a girl with a personality yeah
welcome down Lane yeah we're back in
Ireland I was like I love a girl with
looks yeah yeah yeah I guess it's you
got to come you almost need to get a
girl like you need to mix a girl from
there and here somehow you think like
not really long distance so that's like
that'd be the longest distance it's like
90 day fiancé dude it doesn't work out
it doesn't work out on this show no
one's from Ireland on there ever yeah
there's some English people really yeah
some Brit and used to be you come here
just to do comedy I'm trying I was like
oh my god this guy's nuts I was like
Krystal is making too much money got a
body double what kind of books just
about me been drunk you know they did
you your instagrams hilarious man when
you say all those things about the
things you've heard four different
chicks and stuff yeah it's like turn
into a book really well some people read
hey yeah hey the northern half of the
hey is it audible cause it feels gonna
miss them yeah Brendan's out a mission I
do
Brendan's lucky I didn't fight in UFC
when he fought bro does it means anybody
could make if you would if you were if I
was fighting if I chose in fight and
path when you were in there dog you know
what dude it would have been interesting
you know I would have met you of what
255 what could we have matter whatever
you want brother no 6 plus that's heavy
weight to 600 anything about sixth
fucked-up cool I'll get it okay I can
get Stuart shadow seven yeah - so know
if you saw was gonna clear you leave -
two or seven with a brick in the back of
my face I'd say you'd fight like a [ __ ]
pokey and how do they fight this dog
give up you have to kill him yeah yeah
yeah Tyson Fury he's seen the videos on
YouTube were like it's the pikeys
calling each other out
yes nuts that's a different language huh
yeah no it's English broth it's very
broken English they be like I tried to I
tried to poison you your dark tea scum
I'll find you again yeah it's like dad's
fight that brothers fight it's insane
it's awesome if you enjoy bum fight ya
know it's way better
Wow yeah you know a big bump like
remember big bum fights was this is way
better yeah cuz these dudes fight fight
right
yeah there's no giving off like it's you
it's usually it's usually like two cars
parked at night the lights are on yeah
jesse is that [ __ ] stop okay oh here
you go Doherty calls out yeah what a
coiled that's what he grown up in
Ireland daughters almost like a shredder
fighting was it fun it was fun but he
didn't want to fight a pike he cuz
you're like I have to lose badly
otherwise you're coming yeah if you win
- they'll just be like oh here's his
older brother and if you kill him what
happens do you get anything yeah you're
a trophy trophy it's like everyone
everyone thinks those gypsies look like
Brad Pitt from snatch hey don't not all
of them are shredded yeah they look like
snatch damn you got and you're going
over there man whenever that world heals
up I've been there before I was supposed
to be in Cork in April but then this
disease happen so we'll be in there at
April 2000 2001 though cork but I did
double in two years ago June went with
me yeah oh yes on my line of tattoos
from it we do bow what's up chin want
that on this neck and the guy want to do
it yeah I do want on the net skate house
the first time you can't do it I'm like
I'm so down to do it but he wouldn't let
me do it you should get the whole King
in the sting crew on the back here net
or just the King distinct ball might be
sick to the bolts actually good idea
because I wanted something right there
get the ball devil I also had chin sit
up on his birthday get tatted
can be pumped up I didn't Punk out it
was a different person but now your
person the one I was originally supposed
to do prison prison on Campbell so I
can't do that yeah the other guy was
legit too oh yeah you want some guy from
ink master I was like [ __ ] dude it's
just a nut Tech just a neck tattoo yeah
do you just drive near a prison and have
your car break down your guy killed
someone
yeah well yeah I mean the car but yeah
that's [ __ ] dope it's falling
I guess I'll pound that but I'm gonna
sting that I mean no it's sad that the
guy someone passed away but I'm saying
it makes your tattoo harder I feel like
well I supposed to get so that crash
happened I think on Saturday night or
Sunday and iswhat's I'm on Monday oh I
did texted that morning said hey we
still on somebody accidentally kill
someone with a vehicle Brennan has the
balls to text a guy in the man out still
do my breath I would still know he's not
he's gonna fit it for his uniform in
prison do oh wow made me fine though
cause he can tap those boys up Oh a
ticket I don't think I do any time
though I really don't feel as a good
lawyer he'll be all right I won't be
judged on no no if he killed someone
Brittany think about someone hold on
Sean let's have them vote me and Co
let's say when Thea was drinking with it
was cool when me and you were like let's
say we're drinking right let's even go
out after this and we're both drunk and
I and you agree to get in my car right
you get in my Porsche I wrecked that
Porsche you die should I go to prison
even though we both agreed to get in the
vehicle we've both been drinking you
were buying shots eyes behind shots we
both agreed to this should I go to
prison for life is that murder this
first of all sounds like I want to say
Irish NASCAR second of all is your horn
let them look it's a good question it's
really good question should I get a
prison for life Catholic martyr to
manslaughter by the way in there you
probably hang yourself if you were in
Ireland I would be very upset don't you
yeah heavy lies the crown I would not be
happy but I'm just saying
legally should I go to prison for life
no that's crazy
is there a lot of shame in Ireland
Oh insane what did y'all do just
disappointed god yeah but is Sinead
O'Connor like the I could say she's like
your North Star right she's she's like
your Will Smith no she's your Will Smith
she's like your Britney Spears legit
she's still alive I think yeah she's
alright Dolores Quinta but yeah shame
that's why I don't like sex calming
shame oh yeah I might be i rescind it so
I don't even a jack later probably two
years ago I'll do sex Robin ain't
comment about that's for freakin
children oh man you're the nicest rule
not me dude up you dead white and blue I
bust not July 4th up in this [ __ ] oh my
god you old-fashioned mule and a wet
marketer you start on people in real
time I live by the rules to be crazy
oh man nah man you got a dry dock bro
no ejaculation leave early also mark
what you been doing in this quarantine
dude what would you say you do now you
kind of hang around drink I mean in the
day kind of hang around drink iced
coffee and then at night you do stand-up
at the Laugh Factory
yeah that's gone so what would you say
you do I've been writing sex palms weird
like you got one for us yeah what's up
home it's an erotic tale they paid my
rent last month they do the erotic tales
I don't know it could write like this oh
yeah it's weird I did it as a joke like
Malibu was burning mm-hmm and I saw
people taking naked pictures on the
beach being like oh I'm so sad so I
wrote this dumb
Paul I call it four moves like maybe
like I'm so sad I'm so horny I'm on the
beach
you look lovely Malibu's burnin and this
whole yeah like couples read to each
other before they have sex that's good I
can't get hardened your uh broken glass
no and kids thank God tgd on that one
but I'm going to say uh but uh broken
glass somebody shattered a window or
something you're gone erection gone like
that bro like almost like my penis has
ears it's almost like there might be
some childhood trauma kind of coming
back it could have been maybe yeah I
don't know but it's wild man I one time
this lady threw a slipper like a hard
slipper like a shoe like a note at a
window and shattered it and huh at least
you know you know I'm glad I know some
things man dude one thing right now
health experts they're not always right
which we've learned in this crone at
times but one thing they are right about
a perfect diet doesn't exist man even
when eating a healthy balanced diet can
be tough to cover your bases so Affleck
greens went and they deliver deliver
that greenhorn they send that green hole
that green home ring drops that athletic
greens right in your little stupid mouth
daily all in one health drink with 75
vitamins minerals whole food source
ingredients makes it easy for you to
start living or I praise God baby and
praise others I'm gonna say this
athletic greens includes prebiotics
probiotics digestive enzymes at after
jhin's super foods and more and more
what's in it
oh if it ain't green it ain't ring
that's right live it in powder form and
mix with water I thought greens requires
less capsules has superior absorption
and doesn't include any binders or
fillers no just the green that you need
man fill in the gaps in your diet start
living right that's relative stand a
chance if you're healthy and green green
up hoes down baby you know what I'm
saying hello is this bro I don't care if
you live in Vietnam or Hawaii baby
it's time to take care of your body and
that finally break yeah
I'm too strong dude everybody greens
I like greens man whether you're taking
steps to break in your chair or an
athlete better performance athletic
greens take the guesswork out of your
good health why not just try it jump on
over 200 greens calm /k 80s and claim
the special offer 20 free travel packs
value at $79 with your first purchase
that's athletic green stop / Katz good
luck to you - oh man you know what's so
funny buddy I noticed that flowers are
blooming and the grass is growing and
it's time to mow your lawn oh wow dude
and you know what else ain't cool but
having a bush in the summer no dude I
mean having a bush beer is good but if
you're having that that natural beer
that body bush you know we talked about
wearing George getint have a freaking
afro hanging out the front dude you I
start using man escapes the only men's
brand dedicated to below the waist
grooming yes mayo time of that perfect
package 3.0 young deal you got a trump
that front Jack man that little semen
whistle bro you got to trim it up yeah
semen whistle man how about I give you
some a crop preserver the manscape crop
observer anti chafing bald you're in it
right for them ball sacks right for that
sack dawg why don't you suck on my balls
papa yeah if they're dry and you got
some deal and I'm will see dude for a
limited time subscribers get two free
gifts you guys get the travel bag and
the high-performance anti chafing
manscape boxer-brief this is the perfect
package for yo pack you get 20% free
shipping with the code king sting at
manscape calm that's right get 20% off
and free shipping with the code king
sting all one word King sting at man
scape dot-com 20% free shipping at
manscape comm king sting it's spring
clean and baby yeah give that
ding-a-ling right here's a guy right
here he looks extremely white let's kick
it off with the Bay Club
getting a little debate club here with a
young fella have you seen the show
before mark you know what you're dealing
with just clips I like the honesty at
least yeah fresh what up guys got a
little bit of debate club for you it's
that a home you shoot the six pointer or
a bud take a slap shot Canada versus
Mexico whoo who's a better neighbor Gang
Gang butt plugs
Canadians are so nice they don't do much
for us but they're so nice they got the
hottest chicks up north go to Toronto
get a Montreal gonna bang Coover Ottawa
Winnipeg is gaining a ton of the fame
that would be a good name game name
places in Canada they get the CFL which
actually hurts them they should think
they should fight here on American soil
Canadians yeah like why can't you have
men on fight island have ten
representatives from each make it a ten
on ten like an Olympic type of thing
yeah I guess things are definitely nicer
and there's no cartel up there a lot of
Hells Angels but then I'm gonna [ __ ]
with you max oh yeah we're about the
cartel they have more resources than
anyone they [ __ ] it up her up yeah great
food though they're kind of like
Hayden's got maple syrup salsa for
Mexico just talking about yeah Mexico's
like the office kind of the off-white
Africa a little bit dangerous you're the
wrong part super oh yeah safaris over
the zoo the guy tried to almost get us
in they have fires and we're gonna do it
yeah and then the fire started then we
pass $3,400 you don't have a zoo
basically have Joe exotics before it
happened yeah and then yeah literally a
week later everybody involved in the
deal was burned to the ground so you
definitely more barbecues down in Mexico
like they call the Irish the Mexicans
the Europe why can't you just do like
all the work Catholic and just fun
chances pie
keys will steal again facility and they
do a lot of asphalt over there what else
do you guys do they've all I never do
actually yeah Roofing gypsies are
hilarious thought they literally put an
ad in the newspaper for a car and if you
want to buy it there go and steal it and
then sell it it takes about seven eight
days to Pena one time my uncle saw ad in
the newspaper and he was in the window
it was his car and he's in the wind or
doing the dishes and he phoned the
police and the police were like yeah you
don't want any part of that family so
much fun the Wild West
yeah I'm trying to think Oh God Mexican
girls were hot my wife is Mexican my
kids are half Mexican yeah boxers he's
not gonna good I'm telling you Brock
come up to 2:35 and meet you thought if
I was fighting [ __ ] on them sup with me
have you got off the middle ones got
real juice and then you have to get that
you have to call up your boy I would be
gargling testosterone in the morning my
teeth would be um
dude that's a tough and Wow debate club
who's the better neighbor oh that was
the question I thought it was who would
win in a fight go back to fighting
Canada's a pretty friendly neighbor
Canada simply the better neighbor but
it's definitely more Canadian listeners
yeah I don't know our market in Mexico I
think we have a lot of Mexican American
listeners for sure but do they consider
themselves Mexican or American I guess
it's I don't know me you can be both
yeah yeah so I would say I'd say let
them fight I think I mean eight
sometimes they do let me know America
see a Canadian fight Oh Mexican all the
time America runs on Mexicans Oh true
you know yes undeniably yes like it's
better for the most part
um jeeps what stuff um ma'am
what do you think Kat um I'm gonna have
to say Mexico I grew up in San Jose with
nothing but Asians and Mexicans so I
can't go Canadian well go Canada and do
Asians and Mexicans get along with each
other we either don't get along and it's
terrible
or weird the best of friends it's one or
these no middle ground there's really no
middle ground like I grew up in like I
was cool with all the Mexicans I grew up
with but chin had a terrible experience
at Texas not just Texas when I moved
here I lived in Santa Ana my parents are
still in Santa Ana and Santa Ana is
straight up that's like Mexican Ville
Colo heaven yeah Wow and then they were
mean to you kid very mean this cuz you
were a giant Korean in their City
probably probably a fat chubby Korean
here 300 pounds yeah now is that their
fault no reason to beat me up but yeah
that's no reason to beat him up myself
they won't beat you up and see yourself
because you were big and fat no Asian
yeah Wow skateboards bikes fishing
equipment to be fair you told me that
Vietnamese people did that to you too so
I don't know if it's necessarily like oh
maybe I'm just a sure thing
maybe I skin the trouble off and hold
maybe two maybe it's me I mean not to
say that but it's like common
denominator thank you bro I'll say that
well maybe they you know thank God for
them I feel like kind of like a agent
Doug funnie a little bit
what's Doug funny huh the character he
doesn't know yeah Doug funnie what was
the other Nickelodeon he's like a
drawing man cartoon uh he had his own TV
show
it was Oh Doug yeah he's come
Doug don't you drop his last name thanks
Doug that's a good car yeah my eyes are
one kind of BD so I don't see that man
to get beautiful eyes thank you mmm that
was actually a big inheritance Doug
beautiful eyes Oh
Doug was big here was good Doug why do
people a lot of people hated on it huh
people some people call him a wig or two
I remember was it wasn't it like real
shy and super friendly yes and there's
Patti how does a real [ __ ] right she
always liked [ __ ] tease on him all the
time I think she was she might have been
Dutch or something that's the whole crew
there click on the whole squad his
brother was green remember that threw me
off
there's his blue friend Alda bully
porkchop was the dog
yeah porkchop had her I liked him why I
was good a great cartoon in Ireland do
you guys do you have different who's
y'all's arch-nemesis wouldn't like
woodland yeah all the time because they
stole everything from you guys still
think you have the best time but you
guys are stealing a bags only one car at
a time yeah you can see why they don't
you are you a big whiskey guy like James
yes he is do you know what I I drink
whiskey I rent when we do show they
drink whiskey I come here and people got
me into Guinness and whiskey because
they're like do a whiskey shot you're
Irish and eventually I'm like ah rice
I'd already care yeah but like I'll
drink a drink if someone has it to me oh
yeah we're just do you feel like you're
letting your people back yeah well I was
drinking too much Skinner's lives
getting chubby oh yeah yeah yeah Brendan
I need some how'd you lose the wig get
on get a bicycle join the fig boy bike
club yeah you know any fat kids have
getting hit by cars on bicycles a head
losing weight they might break their
jolly can either way they're losing
weight what about the guys who kill the
fat kids they're all full circle dude
but should they be in jail with
no question we never answered your
question what was it what was the
question if you and I went out drinking
we both agreed to get in the car whether
you're driving around driving and you
crash or I crash and one of us dies yeah
should you go to prison for murder if
I'm conscious now here's F of here's the
point is if I'm conscious and I make the
choice because then I'm really saying if
I'm conscious enough to know you know
we've been doing both drinking right
we've been buying each other shots all
night
I'm almost saying hey I don't want to
take the risk you take it so part of me
is really you know what I'm saying I'm
not really it's like yeah we're gonna go
this party you've been drinking I've
been drinking let's jump in this ride
right but but still it's like if we're
both safe we're both wasted right and we
know we both probably shouldn't be
driving then at that point if I say all
right man yeah you drive it's almost
like me kind of wimping out it's like
nice I'm with you on this too if you've
done that before have you with your
friends I'm dead my frauds in it we're
both drunk and my buddy's like hey I'll
Drive us and I'm like [ __ ] we both need
to get there but the point is we both
agreed to get in the vehicle right
knowing we're both under the influence
yeah you know you have to take some
responsibility for it agree I got no
matter what happened right we should
both take responsibility for it well
isn't the responsibility that one of you
guys died we mean in this thing I was
the risk we both took because we could
have both died yeah so happen for
whatever reason I didn't hit the tree
Theo did or vice versa and we both took
that risk he just got the [ __ ] end of
the stick and also and all unintended
and also I don't think it was upon what
your tattoo artist also hit a tree he
hit a tree but what I don't know I'm
saying is and I'm kind of like in it's
it's not even like against what you're
saying I'm just saying like say if we're
going to get in a car and I say hey man
yeah if I'm like thinking in my head oh
cool I don't want to drive I don't want
to risk me getting a DUI or something
I'm gonna let my buddy drive then it's
almost like me say it's like but you
know the risk okay a great point it's
almost like you know I'm agree with you
I almost know where more it's almost
like I'm I'm like you know the
repercussions like dude if you pull over
you
you are going to jail right and your
buddies at buddy's like hey who should
drive and I'm like if in my head I'm
doing the math I'm like well [ __ ] you
should know ya got one strike I'm
already dressed like I'm going to jail
you know I'm already dressed like I'm
going to prison at Eddie Bauer you're a
dressed like Andre Agassi's gonna be a
punk that's actually true twos that
means you're more soil for it really
it's it so it's a weird
it's a [ __ ] argument I stood up my
brother when we were drinking we were
young we were bored hammered like 14
gonna say four didn't you guys and I was
like uh I got a time I less you go home
first and he'd be drunk he's walking and
my mom's like you're drunk again and I
walk in I'd be like I can't take I can
imagine
Brett showed up to your funeral to on
his bike and he's just like I could have
been me mommy sent me blown to hurt you
know when you get enough DUIs they used
to force your car to have those things
where you blow into it when I was a kid
I was a help alone this is fun for me it
would've been a hell of a lot of trauma
255 blue high-calorie it's like okay you
can drive 36 gram sure you can drive but
it gives you directions not to pass any
bakeries on the way wouldn't it be crazy
in the future of cars if whenever you
blow into the breathalyzer it like knows
how you what you need like physically
and stuff for vitamins everything and it
takes you on a path that keeps you out
of the out of like cool any fast food or
anything don't they kind of fridges like
that
like your fridge noise when you're
running low on stuff
yeah those orders directly yeah I won't
put Mexicans man if you I'm saying
Mexicans that thing you know yeah I want
to go with Mexicans I like cannon more
than netskope my wife is making my
children but I'm drawn to the Canadians
man I love it's fun of shell friendly
business great Jeff ELLs up there yeah
the grass is always greener huh it's
always greener on the other side Wayne
Gretzky's Canadian the grass but the
grass ain't getting mowed bro if you
don't go Mexico that's kind of a cheap
joke it's a tough call man it's such a
tough call are there any Mexican
Canadian people that's gotta be a rarity
I'm sure but I'll be 20 too many there's
a lot of Native Americans in Canada yeah
sir
oh yeah yeah a lot of them ran up to
Canada when everybody was killing them
down here a lot of them were from there
though yeah cuz it used to be all just
one big place you know you should just
be a bunch of Indian people Indian or
Native America running around like aw
[ __ ] we're lost you know yeah Kevin
Canada has a lot of Hell's Angels its
depends I look out I won't say it's a
problem but the other Hells Angels up
there like one of the biggest chapters
is up there I mean I will say loud
mufflers are a problem so I'm gonna go
with yes Hugh yeah nothing ruins
homework right Chan like a [ __ ]
muffler some loudmouth we're going by
which must be a problem in you guys
community that's insane that in the
asian community you guys do homework and
also drive the loudest muffler beers
which makes it so hard to [ __ ] focus
on anything pressure makes diamonds
that's why we do so well I like that
who's this young fella he looks like
he's a Canadian Mexican oh my god what
up world this is Dylan representing
Wisco and now Santa Monica woke up this
morning and read chuck-e-cheese change
their name on GrubHub
to name I can't even pronounce and it
got me thinking what a perfect Rat King
debate who's a better rat chuck-e-cheese
or Mickey Mouse gang gang buzz-buzz now
let me sum be a little biased because
when I was a young man when I was in
eighth grade or seventh grade I lived
next door to Chuck E Cheese and then
this gentleman named Nathan Dunlap from
my high school all right decided to
murder everybody in the Chucky Cheese
and that's rice to hang out really so
Chuck E Cheese this Satan's lair to me I
would never step foot in there again and
it's evil so Mickey Mouse for the win
cuz Walt Disney and Walt Disney World is
fantastic that's Nathan Dunlap Overland
High School Trailblazer
alumni dude that guy looks like nothing
Dunlap dude that got shot up a Chuck
what year was that
yeah dude he's on death row well I mean
I remember this house doing music now no
no he's always actually on death row
dude look you first I'm gonna say did
the Mickey Mouse bro is basically no one
has been extorted more taking it not
extraordinary
no-one's been taking more advantage of
than Mickey Mouse 93 I was 10 here's
thing about Mickey Mouse though to Walt
Disney it's kind of glorified Nazi he
was a Nazi kind of activist I don't know
if people know that about Walt Disney
really that's not an Eddie problem
conspiracy acts yeah still makes great
cartoon since the magical plays but well
yeah he had some different hobbies but
you don't get one one great thing
without the other that's the thing to
say there's two sides of the Tata bruh
I'm going chuck-e-cheese bruh first how
dare you yeah you and did you go to
Chuck E do you bail out on everybody
that dies Brendan okay the guy died in
the car at the tattoo shop he screw that
guy Nathan Kaplan or whatever that
[ __ ] name was sorry F [ __ ]
no that's fine he killed three people
and now you're not going
have Peet's anymore way more than three
yeah I know I'm not going back there
they shut it down they turn into super
salad place yeah that's all this was
left of people after he shot him up
probably too much dude sorry
hey how about also chuck-e-cheese some
[ __ ] with those mechanical like
crazy with her fucked-up eyes they come
out every 30 minutes that was the show
he'd have this [ __ ] trash pizza [ __ ]
that's why no one's buying their pizza
that change the names look at that you
know traumatizing this is a young kid
look at that [ __ ] that's chalk is
Pasquale II put a little effort of those
goddamn dolls there's a monster out
there that's much as make-believe
banging that's what they're called first
of all we'll bring Dean with you which
are missing yours the entrepreneurial
spirit no I'm not dude Chuck you choose
one [ __ ] math look at his eyes this
was gonna be the next Disneyland okay
you don't think this guy had aspirations
you don't think he had a plan and then
Nathan Dunlap said hold my ak-47 yeah
and then it's f tards like Nathan Dunlap
dude who I hope gets the electric chair
and he walks into the place and shoots
up the entertainment while some kids are
having a birthday I think he worked
there and they fired him you try selling
bad pizza in every Trap House
neighborhood in America and see if it
ain't hard to do it's easy to be dizzy
Mickey Mouse when you got a guy
somewhere dude you did well doesn't that
start off [ __ ] with just a Donald
Trump investment but you know from
nothing I got I think Walt Disney the
goddamn world son Disney World
yeah I've heard of it what I'm saying is
though is that it's you just you're
missing the underdog spirit man here you
got a guy selling horrible pizza and
shitty neighbors while kids are crying
yes kids are crying the place is filled
with kovin yeah they had the ball pit
just filled with SARS and [ __ ] armored
planning a piece of strapping the ball
pit and but I'm saying man you're
missing the entrepreneurial spirit I'm
going with Chuck Jesus my god Disney do
you get you get stuck over there in line
there's 700 people in line everybody
likes these
world it's freaking so it's not you get
mucked over there it cost you thousands
of dollars to get your frickin chubby
kid through 900 lines you get sunburned
sunstroke yeah drama doesn't give a [ __ ]
dude and chuck-e-cheeses $7.00 me walk
away with SARS bro huh or you get
murdered yeah
there's never been a shooting at Disney
lady take a chance let's go to Ireland
what do you think man is chuck-e-cheese
real it's a real piece of [ __ ] it's not
a real piece of [ __ ] as an up-and-coming
dude I grew up daxter what you [ __ ] yeah
and it was we went when you were older
doesn't count go in your kid traumatized
wait when I was a kid sick to my stomach
in that [ __ ] pizza and those yeah my
cousin got his freakin arms stuck in the
back of the mouse okay dude Disney
Disneyland does real work there's actual
[ __ ] human beings in those suits all
day 100 degree weather go to Disney
World
they're sweating they're sweating human
beings bro yes there are but I will also
say it is a nesting ground for young gay
men who are using drugs and meeting up
in Florida and Southern California
costumes to do sex with each other
and drugs chin with your banjo and your
[ __ ] pick a side um F when I
remember going to Chuck E Cheese I
remember the the mascot had like a tube
coming out of it and bringing me out
it's called cord yeah budget dude
no more do you want real reason have
both cuz it were gas-powered in the
beginning show that's a choke on it the
only problem bro you guys have who's
gas-powered even fumes rendering the
goddamn ball pit how do you think I
turned out so [ __ ] up man
I spent my summers at Chuck E Cheese
that was your huh no you did that on
your own no I didn't drop us off dude I
drop us off me we'd walk across the
street culture corner what do you guys
think man I can't handle any more I feel
I don't know what a k-hole is and I'm
done for cheese sauce old murder yeah
well why don't you take your baby to
precondition land where an alligator
will eat him no he won't
yes he will Jim it happened that
happened the dude let the kids swim in
the [ __ ] waters of Florida that's not
a Disney problem well that's a Florida
Pro wouldn't happen in chococheese they
can afford oceanfront property that's
not the lesson the ball pit meeting
[ __ ] pizza man I'm going to choke a
kid yeah I'm just fighting with there
anymore it also makes a lot of sense
well but here's the thing bro yeah
because if you the last guy that came
without a kid shot everybody in here you
gotta have a kid man he had a gun and
they pretended as a kid as a gun in a
cashew around the butt of the of an AR
and like all that kids real summers man
I can dunlap said no more summers for
you but Holly can't Thor oh man what do
you think let's get one more well I grew
up in San Jose where there is the
biggest Chuckie Cheese in the nation and
so it was like this crazy two-story
Chuckie Cheese it was great but at the
same time I feel like kids were getting
kidnapped left and right there
- sex trafficking scheme man [ __ ] y'all
[Laughter]
so hey what the fail let's let the fans
debate it would they say 74% Mickey yeah
cuz they're not [ __ ] pedophiles
I want to I'm with the other funny thank
you and I'm gonna say one out of four
fans or listeners chose chuck-e-cheeses
out of respect seventy five percent
chose Mickey Mouse 75 percent well it's
a different amount but I'm about a four
okay fine here's what we learned it's
because a lot of our provide care go
ahead I'm sorry mark right there in
Brendan's and Nazi sympathiser
just because it's what's wrong with you
I think he's like they're like it's
right down the corner there's a bunch of
people there's a bunch of people that
are dressed shittily eating Pete's
inside I bet he was trying to go into
your home bro that's [ __ ] up you need
to look up the case it was after hours
he got fired and shot all the employees
did he really a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ]
not not in America not to [ __ ] Disney
World and did it on a bigger scale
basically the Nazis or didn't or Nathan
done that but more a larger group that's
why you have to go with you hit me with
this young-looking Thor up here yeah
give me with this stop what's up Brandon
sup Thea just got done running
one Greenway here in Smithfield North
Carolina I got a debate club for you so
when you go run and you're gonna put
your keys and phone and your wallet all
up in your your pants and your pockets
be that be that bulgy pocket bozo or you
gonna make them honey's drip drip when
you put it all in your panty drop in
boom pop in fanny pack what was gonna be
boys he pack of pockets he did it Gang
Gang buzzbuzz buzzbuzz young Thor good
luck dude that was a nice running he got
through it but it's a struggle a little
bit got a little muddy there pop pop pop
robbery robbery
Denver's at [ __ ]
I can't
I you know how some people have OCD my
OC I can't have things in my pocket if
you notice whenever I sit down so look
at all the [ __ ] I have out I always
leave a [ __ ] out and then when I ride my
bike think boy bike club I got a fanny
pack we're gonna do think boy fanny pack
that fanny pack what school put jeez put
my nicotine in there I get the gel packs
put my cell phone cords and you hit them
trails
yeah let's seem like fun alright here's
what I do I do something that a normal
person knows I hide my keys in the woods
near where I park [ __ ] gets stolen huh
no I lost my shoe Eugene I did lose my
keys actually once in man ruse I hit him
but usually I put them in the tire well
or I'll put them in the woods nearby
underlie come on stupid [ __ ] man
do you do that before you park it
chuck-e-cheese dude I'm not running with
a bunch of keys on me dude like I'm a
janitor and a fire bro get a fanny pack
dude I'm not getting that all right we
do that in air than two when we left the
house we just find a bucket of stones
and just put our keys in there Kalen did
that stolen just a few weeks ago really
yeah left that bit left the keys in the
car
some dude from Venice went oh cool look
at this gay Prius and then stole it and
then counted found it had crack pipes in
it he found a bum sleep in the back no
way so learn from towns mistake it would
take forever to do that not earth long
enough to learn from his mistake yes
this is a one would you rather use for a
jug pockets i pockets is crazy anybody
that wants a bunch of stuff on [ __ ] man
yeah Danika pockets one fifty three
percent said pockets people are too
scared to look gay listen dude fanny
packs they're not gay it's a movement
man yeah see but if you're a girl you
can put it in your chest pocket your
mama that titty titty pocket yep tip
pocket a little tip man yeah that's a
big and what if you have big enough
boobs
sometimes it's the flat-chested hoes can
do it but it's on high anything in there
really yeah do you do they do people jog
in Ireland it doesn't seem all and we
run in the rain does wrong body feels
really finished last and Olympics it's
like you guys and like Saddam even Tyson
period if you watch Tyson Fury workout
it's like he's working out in his living
room but he's from Manchester right yeah
but he's not like Irish roots I think
what he's a dinosaur bad will eat so
many potatoes and just drink potatoes
Jameson we're like chunky we work out a
lot to get skinny I used to be fast how
fat like chubby kid give me weight how
Paul you like six - okay I used to be
like you'd know I had a big fat face
he's singing one time on TV and I came
home my gran was like yeah you're too
fast that's fair only feedback yeah well
welcome to my Instagram you know Jim was
almost 300 pounds yeah shame is good
yeah Oh fat shaming works yeah like dude
what's wrong with your [ __ ] face oh
my god no down yeah
no you steals line you get stung by a
bunch of bees my
somehow steals that steals yeah it's on
the Beast thing started yeah I called
you the Rat King from Tears written into
Turtles and here we are
welcome to show mark here have you
brought up beyond the arc yet for Till's
look like oh yeah up there debate club
so be with pockets that's [ __ ] insane
dude I only noticed - speaking of
pockets when Brendan emptied his he
carries loose mints lose matches dude
their nicotine Perry alarming yeah with
the headband Oh a little bit god I can't
believe you played with all that long
hair like that what did you just tie it
back to get my hair cut in the garage
tomorrow yeah I'm the way there's people
doing hair in the garage it's law looks
good everybody doing here these days um
now what about this let's talk about
this then because uh we got to talk
about something but what were you guys
talking about oh this guy looks like an
Irish model this gentleman right here is
a Sinead O'Connor Rage Against the
Machine model this guy's coming to kill
ya
there's no chuck-e-cheese where he's at
moving on to rip my earth sink my ink
from white-trash american oklahoma got a
little sing my ink three fellas you know
got the area card the shade 580 on the
arm by my best friend on 17 got in my
dining room table
mom and dad we're pretty happy with me
about that face tagging that J for Jesus
baby hey Louie Vuitton Oh got the cult
leader himself mr. Jared Leto probably
my favorite pieces right here that's
looking wild you got venom
got got the baby mama Harley Quinn on
arm two or I got
love you guys man show kicks ass Gang
Gang Buzz Lightyear he wanted skipped
over that anarchy tattoo on his [ __ ]
big bro but that means if you want some
of his wiener bro you're getting some
INR that's I mean if a woman if she
complained after like hooking up with
him you can't complain they have that
right yeah you know like hey Your Honor
exhibit a this is an turkey tattoo you
knew what you're signing riches from he
kicked in my door
he doesn't need a cache 85 80 I think
that's one of the best things I've ever
heard man out a lot in Oklahoma jabs at
17 in your living room sting it right
hard sting I've made some mistakes yeah
I'm gonna say I'm gonna say King it man
I like that I like I like bad tattoos
that people have gotten some of these
look pretty good man his or those those
Joker ones the the car to the comic book
Joker on his rib piece there's pretty
[ __ ] legit yeah he's got a couple of
Joker's is a black widow tattoo which
usually means you killed somebody in
prison but that's whatever you tattoo
I'm sure he's a model sis and his face
tattoos
Louis Vuitton it's probably the only
Louboutin in Oklahoma oh this dude is
definitely fist-fought somebody at a
Jimmy John's before did I talk [ __ ]
about the Oklahoma Sooners around this
guy look man I'm I guess I'm just a
little afraid to talk but I don't need
that one is a spider I don't even gets a
I think it's a real spider he has that's
just a living the workers on his PEC
right there uh she would have gotten
some more of them and I see tattoos
here's some real [ __ ] on them man I mean
what I like is I like the shady one from
the beginning I think being willing to
let somebody else unless you did it
yourself like this I like that old shady
style like when I was growing up people
would get it with the little thing in
ink and that took forever and the needle
and it was no game plan no sense
so no straight line yeah somebody didn't
even definitely can't even read or spell
with the right your friends
in Mountain View we can handle shaken
hands but you get it done one way or the
other man that shady 580 gang brought
like a man thanks for sending a man dude
moving on this is a half debate club
half a sink my ink hey Brendon a Theo
we're here at Great American Ballpark
we got a king under sting it for you
getting matching tattoos three months
into our relationship
sting it they don't bring this you know
that gay [ __ ]
least if they break up life rips that
could be whatever yeah they're not tied
to life rips to your man yeah where some
people get match that it's tied you know
it's like their name you [ __ ] up son
yeah life rips is cool life does rip
around here you know I'm saying yeah
three one sin is not three months in as
little aggressive
yeah that's support that's aggressive
man but it's a tattoo that's not tied to
her or him but smart what I like is you
can't change it if something happened
you could get life trips or you can get
life life tips life life tips life rips
life trips also you can't get life yeah
you think you could change today oh yeah
the other thing is they decide to go to
the typewriter font which I find
interesting yeah life dips you could get
a can of Copenhagen yeah he says they
didn't get the big one together
I mean look man it's March nemesis Chris
D'Elia saw can't [ __ ] support the
[ __ ] at the same time I love it that you
and your girlfriend care about each
other three months when you know you
know yeah I Fripp's it's a giraffe
that's trippy I'm down for that I don't
see a lot of giraffe Ted yeah I like
that raft bro yeah
sweet wrath bra stretch on the other
you're jealous along next dude you got
that limited neck
I've never been able to look that far
around watch this no limited they said
limited 40% yeah you know how pain
decreasing the woman said I crazy got
hit that physical therapy I bet you said
it Bandon takes your boy long that let
him give you some night he's doing drugs
I thinking he's been he'd really just
sort of got into pornography as you know
you know what not surprised I tried to
give him some words say man you could do
something exciting bro you know do a
special you know ruler or something you
know do something unique nobody else can
do something that stretches your neck
out a device that stretches other people
yeah yeah
snarf real nice like a slinky collection
yeah can you imagine the scarfs he could
sell her slinkys he coulda sold really
real missed opportunity then you can
collab with thick neck they did a class
sizes oh they did do a class with
supreme patty allegedly like screwed him
up a bunch of money for it's a dark web
bro it gets pretty dark this is the like
this is the level after this level of
Kagan estate gets pretty dark okay
there's a lot of chuck-e-cheese meetings
yeah when the shallow end of the Dark
Arts over here then boys about full deep
end yeah they're they're drowning so
yeah 87 percent didn't like these
tattoos man and that's unbelievable
and here's the guy right here he's in
the program what step do you think use
on I bet he's been in probably about
seven or eight years this guy looks like
my brother a little bit actually no it
doesn't look like hey what's up guys
okay crystalline and Bryan Callen if you
kind of mix them together maybe it looks
like Lovato junior
yeah that's what I was thinking too demi
lovato jr. no ruled up guys is Casey
from Los Angeles had a little King and
her sting it for you I know Eddie on the
last fight companion went a little deaf
Jack Russell emphasis I just wanted to
throw it out there Rat King on the next
fight companion King under sting it Gang
Gang buzzbuzz buzzbuzz young man I would
love it I'd love for you to be on the
beach doesn't he look like
Lovato jr. right there oh yes there you
go another one loveth the old came on
the fight campaign Rogan likes the
original crew though I tried getting
Joey Diaz on too you know he just likes
the original four yeah I think if you
have something good that were mean I
would love to go on you know I don't
know enough about fighting I don't think
I don't know I mean like we talked three
minutes about fighting the rest about
random [ __ ] that you and I talked about
so I think you'd be just fine yeah I
mean I think you know doesn't pour a so
it might get your foot in the door yeah
it'd be fun but yeah I don't know I
watch the fights use your text Nick and
ask her to bet on and then I lose some
money and then I go did you give him
Walt Harris over-over II know I stated
that away from that one because I was
like I thought over an easy Pig I
thought Overeem would win but I didn't
want to bet against the guy whose
daughter got murdered I felt I felt
conflicted I went I went three and one I
thought I got lucky on Cheeto Vera
I thought unlucky I thought he won but
then but then I went on a gay and I
thought he lost so I went three and one
that's fun that's really good there's
some fun fight MMA stuff to bet on dude
I'm obsessed
five and seven so I'll return from
pandemic five and seven yeah not great
it was fun I like duh
damage right there like your boy damage
elkins yeah took some damage he reminds
me of every every due to my neighborhood
but now with an adult yeah shady five
like just people who got that kind of
tattoos like somebody would come and be
like hey man look I got the guy from
monopoly on my back and it took
literally seven weeks to do it in
somebody's end of the needle and like a
block
yeah and barely got a ton and then they
got would be sick for like four years
but like a you know blood thing blood
what else do we got here we got somebody
right here how are you not selling these
shirts Brendan
so guys shown in Seattle lifting in my
garage quarantine [ __ ] I know you
know how it is
I got a cleaner sting for you stretch
joints lifted riding bikes you know
whatever Freddy don't see in Spokane
next month getting buzz buzz looking
like to Wingstop drugs thanks bro yeah
the wings don't stop never stop extra
crispy
those wings barely yield this guy first
of all there is a six year old who's
missing his clothes right now
yep in the shorts to the top it's too
tight my man you'd be thick didn't have
let the whole world know dude yeah I
mean I've heard of a shoehorn but I've
never heard of a shirt hole I can't wait
how do you even get into that shirt it
turns around so you look like Beyonce
put on some jeans I love the idea George
snow I love George I want to get some
how you gonna be for jorts but against
[ __ ] fanny packs we go together do
not there ain't a butter and jelly I'm
not one step at a time dude yeah step in
there shallow end let's both get some
George yeah they make all the sense well
it'll have to be that tight though why
don't we have King in this thing George
and on the pocket says buzz-buzz Gang
Gang do a lot of prison sex what do they
think about jorts and stuff like that in
Ireland do they have no house the
fashion house the Fashion Island we like
scarves and stuff we don't like Jarts
yeah yeah scarfs a lot of hats but not
like a lot of like paper boy oh yeah
yeah our peak oil jackets yeah we all
dress the exact same you have to wear
like black shoes getting into a pub or a
club
sometimes if you forget black shoes you
your friend gives you black socks and
you put them hand over your white shoes
pretty cool this guy needs my advice for
him just go one size up and everything
so feel like I think I wear a medium get
the large dude but also double X you
know you know wear medium yeah yeah the
George so I think are kind of alright
looking on this summer is coming dude
let's do it some you have no pair of
jeans we bake Karl George do bring some
of your [ __ ] old jeans around if
Bregman has to have a lot of charge I
celebrate the guys out son's outside I
mean I'm willing to put my legs out I
just don't want to I don't you have that
peach popping off the back nope dude
doesn't for you the other day he goes he
said I'm gonna get you and Keith
Peterson to fight at 165 oh the ref with
the ref looks just like Nick Swardson
basically there's no doubt that Nick
Swardson will play Keith Peterson a
biopic are you working up some pictures
of these guys I'd rather see you and
Keith yeah I wanna see you and Keith
Peterson [ __ ] fight Nick Swardson
yeah if Nick I don't want my rough jug I
don't want my life in his hands be as a
neck tattoo it's a bad idea I think you
do dude I'd rather see you and keep you
in a spelling bee than a fight and
sometimes why baby let's see if they got
Nick Swardson in there yeah Nick
definitely looks like him a little bit
enough huh yeah that picture right there
to the right and the left of that one
yeah or actually one you chosen is good
you look so he looks a little like if I
can see it yes yeah shave his hair
imagine Nick was your Ref oh my god a
string for a real fight Brent and
the ref was justified to fall does that
have right did that ever happen where
you would get in sometimes you would
look at the wreck and the rest Royce had
like Big John or I had Herb Dean or you
know because when they're heavyweights
they usually have the good raps there
but like Dominick Cruz said when that
Keith dude came in the back he was like
can is there I can veto this yeah the
[ __ ] neck that - yeah no way like
alcohol and cigarette now am I saying
he's on alcohol cigarettes no those are
Dominik cruises were yeah I don't I
don't know key fishing and deliver a
chucky cheese pizza in here right now
yeah but I love it Dominic cruises I do
can I get a different ref the
Commission's like now is who you were
assigned man Keith Peterson's legend man
I think he's my favorite right I think
you're loose on the term legend
really dude he's no nonsense man nobody
else has is that you've never seen her
bean is he now I'm seeing Big John the
best of the best
yeah confusion just a guy those other
guys are like they've been doing it
forever
he learned from them I would imagine
yeah easy on the term legend though you
know right well what was the last we got
to do what was the last one we just did
it was jorts I'm all for George Smith
the only thing we gonna start the
movement now the summer's finally hit
and let the jorts hit your cheeks out
dude
they're always out no they're not man
you're it's horrible hide them I keep
getting charts ads on Instagram and it's
via command like how was my life what
have I done wrong
those whitey legs out it's a whitey
bulger let's out for Underpants I'm John
Stockton belt for the famine Stockton
had some gams on a wood if you see a
man's leg and it got short shorts on cat
how does that resonate with you is that
uh depend on the leg I think it really
depends on the confidence the legs do
make a difference to like that guy was
just rocking he didn't care that it was
too tight on him but his legs were juicy
so I'm it's not bad exactly if you got
it flaunt it yeah he had huge legs he
has a frickin those wet market
you know hey my boy look like a squatter
[ __ ] chucky cheese right now dude I'm
tell you I got these with Marcus bad oh
yeah we're going to hell man no we're
not
yeah we are Brendan stop watch most of
the episodes one time I was alright I
was in a Irish hospital and I was
getting like an STD check and they had
me like my pants down penis out the
whole shebang and I narses like you mind
if I bring in some training students she
brought it like four women
I was texting one of them oh wow I was
like oh hi and I just naked from the
waist down but she knew ice but yeah it
was like tiny saw that snake what are
the odds of that what ever since my legs
have been hidden away real white legs
always hide yeah that's like to you on
the guess that's like me can you tan or
no oh yeah I love a good tan I just come
to be pop I find that hard to believe
no no I'm beautiful with a tan oh yeah
that's stunning what do you got Nick
another debate club welcome guys
I'm from Glasgow or Glasgow steel would
call it doesn't it illegal yeah
so I strap up with that gun dog can't
get this thing it boys dogs in a harness
a little hound on your chest
oh shut up Glasgow it's kind of like
cows saying with legs you can wear
Georgia tonight let if you have nice
legs
you sport a nice fresh pop on your chest
if it's the cute pup don't put them
little ugly pugs in your chest and [ __ ]
man or yeah yeah or you got a Boston
Terrier with this dick or you got a
wiener dog and like half but you only
see people doing small dogs I would like
to see somebody with a [ __ ] rocking a
great name you know yeah get that
[ __ ] lab on your chest
chocolate lab dude yeah it could be in a
little huh dog tough man
build up them thighs get some George
yeah throw them shorts on and get you a
little don't get you like a little
Pomeranian
no that's for [ __ ] man yeah get that
British Bulldog get that English Bulldog
just hang out well they don't have do
they have the little dogs like they do
in the US do they have those in Ireland
no yeah Terriers but not use that oh
it's Stratford Shire Terriers yeah but
like yeah it's usually big ones
Labradors or Saint Bernards I don't know
what the [ __ ] they're my aunt at a dog
he's a chase Mima brought around a house
and she's like he's only having fun well
he's trying to bite us what kind of dog
was it more exotic dog dude over there
every time I give him the spaniel for I
give him the car goes comes laughs it's
what his cocker spaniel dog one of the
other baby I'm still afraid of dogs
though my brother like ran into a
sliding door like a glass door boss his
face often the Glasgow smile doctor hair
come like stitch of Arthur yeah so no if
I see a dog back and I just that gets
your brother really that's yeah
the glass door sound like the iris
Olympics asking key nursing it dogs and
harness Oh Kenya but it has to be the
right kind of dog don't be putting the
little [ __ ] dogs in the chest man yeah
I wouldn't mind seeing a great day in a
husky at Chow I used to share a room of
the Chow not an Asian guy like is it
really yeah charge house do my god they
are they're violent looks like little
teddy bears dude strapped a cane corso
to your chest yeah it goes for you man
here that 200 pound animal hug yeah do
some work man - switch off like a woman
with big breasts those things like feel
now I empathize their violent ChaCha's
on me yeah hoarsely no they bite more
people than pitbulls problem yeah
they'll pretend they're sleeping and
when you try to leave the room the paid
oh I think that's more of you probably
know well I rented a room University
Arizona from my guy up there your
roommate was a Joe and I got there and
he said the only problem with this room
you have to my dog stays in here so
every night bro it would be so scary oh
they stink too right
huh they stink too I didn't smell him I
just lived near it
what's this little thirst trap what do
you want to adapt to his next high
school movie we'll close it out with our
relationship advice sup tits McGee
what's up Brandon I wanted to get a
little relationship advice from you guys
so this past quarantine I've just been
staying at my girlfriend's house and her
grandma lives with her and her grandma
will not stop hitting on me like she's
clearly trying to make some moves and I
was just wondering like I don't want to
be disrespectful there she's very old
and like my girlfriend loves her
obviously so how do I like you know tell
her what's up without you know
disrespecting her and my girlfriend
that's all I was wondering hope you guys
can help out Gang Gang buzzbuzz game
breath old ladies need dick that's
what's going on here dude she's thirsty
for this young 21 Jump Street fella you
feel me get her some petty grams dude
get us some graham crackers then mold
ladies like graham crackers gotta keep
her pipe down keep her busy dude keep
her busy your crossword puzzles dude
yeah I think that's good it's the core
Jerry Springer's old Jerry Springer's
[ __ ] love that the mold [ __ ] love
that damn finger what's up dude
grandma ain't gonna be worried about
your [ __ ] let me worry about Jerry
Springer I don't mean I think I don't
know she's worried about his [ __ ]
Brendan I think she's just hitting on
him a lot you know it sounds like it
sounds like grandma's lonely thanks
maybe just hang out maybe sign her up on
wrinkles calm or the [ __ ] they have for
old people dating apps my hair's getting
messed up
oh he's messed up you're fine okay I
want to know I want to let this young
man know first of all dude what cheap
young man is shacking up with his
girlfriend and her grandmother during
quarantine or any teen okay I don't
think it's ever a good time to go live
with your girlfriend in our grandmother
especially if the grandmother unless the
ground was cooked into a laundry and
stuff and you're eating at 3 o'clock
it's your last meal of the day she goes
bet around 4:00 do you I think you got
to get a job man you got to get out and
about I think you need to establish a
little bit dude if you don't have a
place and your girls stay in there man
and the role is that you're over at your
girl's place then you get what you get
bro yeah I'm saying give em a little
sneak peek it's last thing you do from
[ __ ] feeding off all their groceries
and [ __ ] yeah do it's your rent son
flirt with the grandma do anything yeah
we tease yeah tickle that old back strap
bra you know what I'm saying give her a
back rub your [ __ ] pedophile yeah
dude quit milling around the house
leeching off of a woman and her ill
grandmother semi ill sexually motivated
that lonely ground give her a back rub
tossing that [ __ ] hot tub dude she'd
have a great time yeah you know he's not
in your situation young men who have
their own apartment yeah young love
their [ __ ] two-handed yeah get your [ __ ]
in two hands and then go like this son
yeah I think you got a freaking take
some ownership mang you get what you
would you allow yourself to give yeah
dude buy a box out of Golden Girls and
tell her shut the [ __ ] up I wouldn't do
that I would get the set and say thank
you guys for letting me live here or
that you know I'm trying to say yeah
I'll tell you what better be doing these
little [ __ ] wearing a mask the mold
people are dying left and right if
anyone should be worried about Kobe it's
probably this grandma that's why she's
hitting on you that's a good point maybe
this fine heavens doorstep ready to get
the [ __ ] out of this world dude yeah and
you're out here little thirst-trapping--
meeting back not wearing a mask yes you
probably trying to get you to pop hop
into that slick - one more time before
she leave the earth so I think you got a
- look man do work or get out man yeah
whining us ain't gonna help it yeah
don't hate the wrinkles bro we got
enough of our own problems we're trying
to kill each other in a car accident
yeah and then we're trying to see if one
of us can go to prison for life you got
problems is grams being sweet open her
arms god damn dude get your life
together yeah dude it is together it
looks like he stole the granddad's
clothes like he dresses looks like an
old man
maybe it's the granny being like ah this
is this is this is Jerry my husband she
might just be lonely as [ __ ] man what do
now in you guys's cultures what kind of
stuff we do what do grandmother's you
their vote you feel like a stronger
position than they do here in a minute
let's take more care of them right yeah
Asians are very family-oriented and you
also your grandma's lived at 200 so the
yeah absolutely
they're gonna be around forever so you
better get used to it yeah you gotta get
used to it
chin you take care your grandma's in
[ __ ] still yeah our grandma used to live
with us and then she was just like I
said she's a smoker drinker smoke every
day like constantly amen she didn't die
from that she got hit by a car she was
like very very late her dark who was
driving the car and who was
the passenger seat and we went to jail
yeah oh she drinkin and did you agree to
get in the car then she wrecked no but
by the way the person that drove was
Mexican Wow was it uber no they what
there's no Cooper back then what was it
taxi no it's just a car no cars it's a
person oh she was crossing the street in
the Mexican she was buy a bus stop this
once a Canadian or Mexican that's how
she passed away
that's not smell sweat oh my that's so
Irish Car Bomb yeah also known as frog
how old was she I think she was in like
late 70s early early eighties and that's
young for Asia
yeah just getting started it's late high
school yeah like half of her life
constantly never didn't have a smoke
never spit balling ideas here wearing
this regal truss which she changed
smoking and played the slots I don't
think we ever took it to a casino
wow that's but if you did you probably
would 100% you don't change smoke and
not play this one she barely lived I
know well she looked crazy life but how
crazy drinking and smoking all the time
sounds like she lived and she was strong
too
well she very strong she says what she
bench I don't think she's a vegetable
picking up stuff all the time
Karen stuff around the house yeah moving
our bikes how strong very strong how
strong I would say if I was her age I
wouldn't be as strong as her you weren't
strong meet me at 240 Sun difference
grandma how strong then there's weight
room strong I'd like to see your grandma
bench 315 what's up mark what about
grandparents in Ireland what is that
what do you like stick around the house
no I've never seen them in an old folks
home Renton they don't do that stand the
farm but then they're drivin they're
like 80 for driving yes crashing into
people but they're not going fast enough
you know yeah driving tractors oat milk
and cows there's a lot of respect with
old people there yeah big time oh yeah
because they've good stories so funny
like your teeth will pop out and it was
like okay you some knowledge me oh yeah
grandma grandpa still life mm-hmm I got
one grandma alive that's it oh yeah what
does she like
she's about 300 pounds uh I used to hide
Snickers under her bed oh yeah yeah she
swims every day even now she's like 98
or 99 300 pounds since I've known her
she swim every single day what does she
bench swimmin pool yeah you know in the
one-piece at the YMCA that vegetable oh
yeah just swimmin and George she's
nothing that one-piece Sun bro what
don't we got water jorts I'm all about
George in general you know I really am
too man I think everything is headed
that direction because yeah well it's
just like more comfort it's like people
are wearing comfortable stuff everywhere
now you know like it used to be people
are in business suits and stuff and now
people especially coming out of
quarantine what's it gonna be like
everyone's in sweats these days could be
wearing a hammock does this look like
your [ __ ] bedroom put some clothes on
a winch sweats all the time the airport
man yeah a little pride you know myself
King George yeah the ball to V charts
and scarves not notes you can see that
George George man you're not taking out
the front sometimes mmm yeah that
pressure yep you know always got to get
out well new king on this thing Murch -
it should be out maybe into this week so
yeah check out an Instagram for that and
american-made american-made so we're
excited about that so if you don't like
America then print out for you yeah
Canada versus Mexico God that one's
still - the real war yeah the real war
the war of King and stay for one for us
where we hold it probably shows up God
do I think it'd be a great battle
I think Canada's gonna become the new
America so I mean I think some of you
are gonna start moving to Canada in the
next 20 there are lots down more than we
are
well I just think just for overall just
for the vibe of the culture I mean I
feel like it's still like you
kanna's nuts for a second what goddamn
dude you've been on there nuts
the only reason I was able to get on was
cuz you just stepped off of them it's a
one-seater on their nut that's fair come
on max those nuts now yeah what do we
got here neck that's it what is this I
we just put a pole for our hypothetical
if Brendan drove drunk with you in the
car you knew he was drunk and you died
should Brendan go to prison seventy-two
percent say yes
seventy-two percent of people don't take
personal responsibility I think yeah
which is why they set price celebrate
the lockdown to take a little pride it's
interesting yeah I think yeah it's like
but I think overall it's like everything
we all have to take more responsibility
but I also doesn't say there Brendan and
through were both drinking they decide
to get in a car Brendan was the driver
that would be in the way should it right
I worded it cuz this looks like
Brendan's drinking picked up Theo
crashed Theo died but Theo knew you were
drunk are you in it you're assuming that
what Theo was can read I should Brendan
go to prison well then poles are a tough
sell
that should be the other Pole prison
bright bike club by two miles in on the
yard we had two months they just have
one bike they're all sharing it do they
have two seater bikes in Ireland peloton
Bay it's too fancy two seater bicycles
there ain't nothing gave them a
two-seater bike maybe a banana seat who
can't be fancy in Ireland people will
mock you straight away
really Oh straight if you if you wear a
hat they'll be like Oh talk a little bit
homosexual daughters Irish and they go
pretty hard in the paint for him and
he's a stylish dude yeah but a lot of
people don't like him either
well yeah he's made some mistakes yeah
so it's very split yeah I'll still the
most famous guy come on oh yeah by far
is it
no I don't think so you think one more
name of Morten Olsen Oh bono bono you
too yeah
probably farce right now yeah McGregor
you you too lost me when they forced me
to and they [ __ ] download the entire
[ __ ] album to my playlist remember
when they did that yeah and it was so
hard to call it off yeah no you can't
slander you two with me here calm feels
pretty black I believe the booth the
best band in the world give you know I
know [ __ ] out I like I like Robert De
Niro's Irish Colin Farrell to us was
Liam Neeson yes now that's huge
Liam least have you ever seen the thing
Liam Neeson pisses his pants in public
and doesn't care I heard he just has
those hilarious pictures of him I just I
heard he has an uncontrollable hog yeah
that's what they should Google Liam
Neeson pissing pants you should beat his
pants but he's just out in public with
it but it tastes Denny in trouble he's
doing promotion for damn that you know
dude you know gangster that is so bad I
don't give a [ __ ] I'm gonna piss my
pants I'm in taken here wow what a move
without Alpha move but you know used to
box too he's like a real tough guy and
he's like six five bro I remember one
time I went to this thing called beta
breakers in San Francisco and they had
it was like a race like people racing on
their feet and um and uh a me and my
friends took a bunch of mushrooms and
went out there and they home I know what
I'm talking about they had uh you
couldn't know it hold on okay and they
people were oh yeah and so I was taking
pictures people would come up and want
to take a photo or something of you yeah
and so I would take one but I would keep
my penis out during the photo as I had
on like some on those really good day
glasses or something and so yeah this is
when people had cameras right and they
didn't know yeah no idea just having my
junk hanging out classic that's a me-too
movement and 20 oh yeah and then we took
over we we got in the race and somebody
had deserted a water table where they
were handing out water cuz it's like a
20 mile run like a lot of people do
serious yeah and then some people just
do costumes and stuff so we took over a
water table somebody left and where
people were running by like and we're
like no it's for Asians only that food
that so you'd have people run up like
white people and they couldn't stop to
argue because they had to keep going
because there is only man sorry what a
[ __ ] show
bro bro mushrooms all day we had so much
fun man hi 14 years like if you're at a
pub drinking and your friend would be
like to a girl he'd be like oh you want
to see my a pack she's like okay and she
lifts up his top and his testicles
nothing gave her the wieners gay if you
had that submarine peeping up the top
nightclub would time in Ireland's and I
was dancing with a girl and I was
getting to turn on and I was like ah
[ __ ]
and I like talked it up I was drunk and
dancin and she lifted up my top why do
you think why do people hide their
wieners so much that's Robert you know
that thing popping out bro this is so
crazy though it's just a stupid wiener
yeah but like I even even if I was at
that Club and your dick came out I just
I wouldn't bring a tent about the top
the head in there for me I was a sixth
grade man I was in sixth grade and I had
this dime piece next to me Isis get them
on control oh my god dude nothing was
units
oh I miss all that how I miss it and I
would just take that thing and crank it
to the top
crank that Hank I don't have to get a
buddy to come over and help me push it
over to this I saw might even have to
tie it off around my leg oh you are
sharpen the pencils now kids can't even
really get boners it's like a crime I
think to get a baby get when you got to
talk about it yeah or they'll tie a rope
around a kitten keep all the blood at
the top of his class different times
anything else we got knit mmm that's it
how about I'm going back on the road ugh
are you and be that guinea pig for the
comics I'm in Houston next week those
shows are sold out but them and spoke in
end of June and then Salt Lake City wise
guys in July dang congratula-- Salt Lake
City wise guys Congrats I'll probably be
in jorts can't promise much after these
targets and I'm getting my hair cut
tomorrow in a garage over there in
Racine I got a Barbara if you need a
legit guy to come to the crib yeah yeah
dude how good was a little brow last
week ah oh he was so good love him him
in Hannah Barron yeah she was great
everyone keeps asking me for going
noodling McKay what if we figure it out
I'm down I'll noodle with her any day of
the week I go there she's like 5 foot so
it was surprising I feel like she gets
some real grappling matches with some
big catfish like it's pretty evenly
matched mm-hmm I don't know the odds on
her next outing but I don't know and how
do we figure out the candy cane numbers
makes it how do you figure that out I'd
easier to wait till more wars happen yep
the only time would tell I still like
that Brendan went Canada me sort of
families mix again I love with all my
skips dude yeah we'll see if those if
the walls get done
yeah hey that's what we love about the
show man a lot of cliffhangers brothers
les yeah your best Brennan and Theo
fighter and wait I gotta go in and go
hard in the paint I do not think I am in
Flo black rifle coffee I'm ready to go
I need a sponsor I am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts Flo is
contagious browser outrageous thicker
than girls leather Instagram famous damn
I'll be like a fresh off keto see a red
like Andrew Santino right every Sunday
is like the great Bambino we're gonna
take the case oh and the case Cerritos
but everything's gonna be fine
hate on me I do not mind got a pack of
matches in his pockets at all times
they sliding into my DMS a couple of you
Trevor couldn't beat em quit playin like
Nintendo DS you don't want the smoke
like Joey Diaz meaning y'all edible just
got my eyebrows threaded and I'm feeling
incredible Brit and Sun him me up he
said it's true loud in the club can you
pick me up a sting
and the sting bee sting King King King
[Music]
got that cheese on a string
as a sting King and the stinking in the
sting bee sting Rat King
and a stinking anesthesia cheese mystery
Brendan and do fighter in Creole
shoutout New Orleans and shout-out to Co
Colorado more specifically Boulder
Brendan came in with a chip on his
shoulder but is still gold and yet it
still fire refute all like King Aniston
you're a liar Brenda's got like a
thousand different hustle one of them's
that norstrom rector went I yours black
rifle club VP hear you loud and clear
your son on the email like please get me
out of here it's way too loud in here
watching the Irishman eating pizzas
drinking half a beer now under Theo von
looking like the tepid do the Tresor
Rita songs smoking cigarettes with a
snapback on that's a hit the [ __ ] intern
snapchat on it's all do we still mess
with you 18:11 Pico Boulevard go get the
head Deborah can cat y'all doing great
Thursday upload not a minute late y'all
wanted to wrap a head a demonstrate
brand new studio y'all feelin great
putting Chris Delano in this place now
let's go and get your nerd painting
and the sting
in the sting bee sting cracking
and I stink
and then stay
in a truck got the cheese on a string
and the sting back king in the state
king is a sting bee sting crack
and a sting okay and a sting gotta beez
in the trap gotta cheese on a strong
[Music]